plus de déchets dans la nature et plus
d'erreurs de tri possible aux
clayes-sous-bois le parc de diane est
depuis plusieurs mois équipés de
poubelles be fluent c'est tout
simplement des poubelles s'ils voulaient
où on peut vous avez un côté de la
poubelle vous avez un côté gris c'est
plutôt ordures ménagères résiduelles et
vous avez un côté jaune avec sky rossi
clap c'est à dire les canettes le carton
le papier depuis un an la ville
multiplie les actions contre les
incivilités et la gestion des déchets
lors d'une action clean up des les
volontaires avaient ramassé plus de 170
kg de déchets dernier équipement
installer des cendriers scellés au sol
ou en hauteur ces mégots ensuite sont
traités vont être on va récupérer le
plastique à l'intérieur des fils et qui
va ensuite servir à fabriquer des
meubles du matériel de bureau des
crayons de paul crayon on n'est pas dans
l'interdiction n'est dans la prévention
et c'est avec cet esprit là qu'on a
essayé d'aborder toutes ces questions-là
23 cendriers ont pris place dans
plusieurs lieux de la commune
certains seront amovible et prêté lors
de manifestations un simple geste grâce
auquel les mégots au sol seront des
vestiges